this morning floating an idea to connect
millions of Americans to the internet
according to the Federal Communications
Commission about 19 million Americans or
six percent of the U.S population does
not have access to broadband service
that allows them to connect to the
internet the Biden administration's
infrastructure act has allocated
65 million billion dollars excuse me to
fix that but in New Mexico one man isn't
waiting he's launched his own solution
to bring the internet to hard to reach
places John Blackstone has the story
in Roswell New Mexico the launch of an
enormous silver air ship doesn't have
the Roar of a rocket but in Mission
Control chief of operations Stephanie
Luongo finds plenty of excitement in
what's being tested I like the idea that
we're going to change the world and
we're going to revolutionize Earth
observation and providing Broadband to
the underserved this test flight is an
attempt to show that a big balloon can
do things that rockets and satellites
can't do we are going to disrupt the
satellite industry once we get this
operational inside its hanger before the
launch the huge aircraft Towers over
everything and everyone but please don't
call it a blimp is this a blimp this is
not a blimp Michael vestergaard and his
company Sky designed and built it so
this is a stratospheric aircraft we
refer to it as a haps high altitude
platform station and the purpose of it
is to go to the stratosphere above 60
000 feet so above the controlled
airspace and stay over an area of
operation Vester guards High out
High L1 station is meant to float in a
fixed position in the stratosphere above
where airplanes fly but far below where
satellites orbit this aircraft will go
up and basically hang in the air over
one spot on the earth absolutely so we
are filled with helium for the lift we
have solar panels on the top side of it
with batteries on the bottom and we use
that and the aerodynamic shape to point
into the wind and stay over an area of
operation it won't carry humans but
besterguard has high hopes for what his
haps can do when it's equipped with
cameras remote sensing instruments and a
Broadband antenna whether that is human
trafficking prevention or legal phishing
prevention ocean conservation methane
leaks monitoring oil detection or
Wildfire rule connectivity there's huge
need those are lofty goals but
besterguard has a track record for
developing life-changing and life-saving
Technology I've built companies in in
public health in food Security in safe
drinking water his company lifestra
developed a water purifying filter
providing clean drinking water to
millions and mosquito killing bed nets
produced by Vester guard have helped
reduce Malaria deaths by more than half
by May of next year we will have
distributed a billion Nets and in the
process seeing Global malaria rates go
down from 1.3 million people mainly
children dying every year to last year
less than five hundred thousand
his newest project also aims to help
people in need this time in need of
internet access this is meant to help
those that are unconnected and under
connected be included in the advantages
of a network World whether that is
education online banking online Health
there's a whole lot of Navajo Nation out
there there's a whole lot of there out
there John Bedell the founder of sacred
wind Communications is working to
provide internet access on sparsely
populated tribal land in in the
southwest on the Navajo reservation
itself in a three-state area the
availability of broadband is very low I
would estimate it's probably no more
than 40 percent and even at that 40
percent the speeds are not that high in
tribal meetings Bedell has heard many
stories of the need for connection and
one grandfather stood up and and he said
I don't know what this internet thing is
all about but my grandchildren do and he
says that my grandchildren won't come
and visit me on weekends anymore because
I don't have internet but providing
internet access throughout the Navajo
nation's 25
000 square miles is a colossal task it
would require companies to install two
to three hundred Towers how long would
that take maybe 10 years or more and the
cost would be enormous enter Michael
vestergaard's high altitude platform
station sitting at about 65 000 feet
over New Mexico it's designed to deliver
broadband internet connection over
hundreds of square miles he is using a
technology that he has come up with
himself to reinvent an Airship to
provide Broadband Services over wide
swaths of the earth you know and this
can not only be used in New Mexico of
course it could it has usefulness
worldwide in in the third world you've
done many projects this seems different
what led you to this project well it's
not all that different because
most of what I've done in life has been
building companies that have all the
same technology platform essentially
which has been around Material Science
this big silver object that looks very
metallic and very solid is actually a
fabric so if you take a look at this
it's something that can take shape you
can cut it and it feels like a piece of
paper David Kim leads the team of
Engineers and chemists who developed the
fabric that makes the Airship possible I
mean it's light and thin and yet it can
survive at sixty thousand feet
absolutely so this is light and thin but
if you've taken it one inch strip of
this it can hold 300 pounds so if you
add that up that's many many hundreds of
pounds thousands of pounds of this
material can hold do you see a time then
when airships like this will be around
the Earth in many places that this will
be the standard replacing with many
satellites do today I absolutely
Envision a future where this will be as
normal as seeing ships in the port as
normal as seeing cars on the road and as
normal as seeing trains on the tracks
and as normal as having access to the
internet for CBS Saturday morning John
Blackstone Roswell New Mexico
there's a track record there I'm not
counting that guy very cool yeah what
they've done with life straw and the
mosquito Nets makes huge differences
around the world but don't call it a
blimp don't call it a blimp high
altitude
station which doesn't roll off the
ground but but you know you consider 19
million Americans who don't have
Broadband access and what what kind of
education what kind of resources the
internet provides for all these people
that he could potentially change one
person at a time right and that
grandfather with the grandson that
doesn't come visit that there's the
personal story to it that's exactly it
Great Piece